foreign
let's go to Susan in Phoenix what's up
Susan
hi Dr John uh it's great to speak to you
you too what's up
well I'm a co-owner of a small business
and one of my roles at the company is to
manage HR in the office so you know
hiring firing how small issues uh we
have about 10 people at any given time
so it's pretty small HR in an office of
10 people is like managing brothers and
sisters and cousins exactly and there's
always a couple of weird cousins oh geez
good for you congratulations yeah yeah
so sorry yeah what's up no worries
um so I've noticed kind of an increase
in mental health issues um that I've
Arisen probably since covid but frankly
just generally speaking I think the
world is kind of creating a lot more um
mental health issues in people
so my broad question is just in my role
how do I show empathy and compassion for
individual struggles while still getting
work done in the office and getting
productivity out of my staff so you know
people are struggling with depression
they're they have you know divorce
issues that I've been encountering
marital problems uh crippling anxiety
you know these are all things that are
really impacting you know their
productivity so
um do you have any suggestions and I can
get into specifics if that would help
um let me make some broad suggestions
and then come back if I don't answer
your question okay okay and I'm having
this conversation all over the country
I've talked to Business Leaders all over
the United States on how to create these
systems and their businesses and here's
a couple of operating principles for how
to do this okay so first and foremost
good for you for being a a business
owner that cares good grief thank you
thank you thank you treating your
customers like Widgets or like robots
for you to make more money thank you for
being somebody who sees people as humans
that's awesome
um so yes there is an influx there's
just a kind of a big reveal and it
happened over overnight here in the
country we're all kind of figuring out
what to do with it everybody's talking
about mental health stuff right yeah and
it's suddenly overnight become okay to
tell your boss I'm depressed or I've
been I've been diagnosed with OCD or
something like that
there's also been
a what I would say not healthy
over sharing that has happened and I
think it's it's chat rooms or something
Have bled over into real life
where people are announcing in staff
meeting I cheated on my wife and now
she's left me and it's like whoa whoa
whoa whoa dude we make boxes like that's
between you and your therapist and you
and your pastor or whoever you and your
friends
um and so there's been this weird
culture of oversharing that's emerged
overnight and here's the deal
it's a weird moment in history where
somebody can drop that kind of grenade
and if you say the wrong thing you're
the bad guy right like if you stumble
over like well uh
you're evil because you didn't fill in
the blank right you didn't accept me or
you judged me or now I'm more anxious or
whatever right yeah so
um here's a I'll give you three three
things that I would recommend
um you you do to create a culture of
both mental health and hey we still have
a business to run here okay
it's it's compassionate but it's also we
got stuff we got to do okay the first
one is this is about relationships with
appropriate distance
and you're gonna let your people know
hey we are a safe place if you're
struggling let us know and we will
support you the best we can here's what
support means
I do not want to know your diagnosis
unless it's coming from a medical doctor
and you need an ADA accommodation for
your workplace
um I don't want you like don't ever come
in and say I've never told anybody this
but I'll stop somebody and say whoa whoa
whoa I shouldn't be the first person you
tell I don't know what you're about to
say but it shouldn't be me I don't know
you that well I'm your boss or
you might tell me something that as your
supervisor I have to act on
okay if somebody comes in and says hey
I'm really struggling with anxiety when
I get anxious I steal stuff
well you can't work here if you're
stealing from us
and the response isn't I've got anxiety
though no you can't steal it's both and
okay so I tell people this is a safe
place here's what that looks like hey
I've been struggling a lot I'm seeing a
counselor can I knock off at four once a
week Absolutely I'll even pay you for
that hour
that's what relationship with
appropriate distance looks like hey
everybody I've got a I've posted a list
of 10 counselors in this local area and
I posted in the break room and I've got
to deal with him if you tell them you
work at our place I'm going to pick up
25 or half the tab so your visit will be
50 bucks go in there you don't even have
to let me know they'll just bill me
directly
okay okay that's way like you are
letting them know you care about them
here's a resource
but I don't know what to do when you
tell me you have major depressive
disorder and you can't come to work but
you still need me to pay you I don't I
don't know I don't I'm not trained to
deal with that I'm not trained to deal
with your suicide response that's why
I'm gonna if you tell me you're suicidal
I'm calling 9-1-1 every single time
because that's not my core competency
I'm not trained in that okay
okay and you're providing them resources
to the professionals that can get them
the help they really need right right
the second thing is this
um and this isn't popular but this is
reality
mental health challenges in the
workplace are a context not an excuse
okay
yeah I am a guy who has suffered
profoundly from anxiety in the past I
don't struggle at all with it anymore
not even a little bit but in the past it
it laid me low
I had two responsibilities there one I
had to get my job done that my boss was
paying me to do
and I had to do the work on my own to go
get well
and in my particular office place I let
people know a few people privately hey
I've got a knockoff to go see a
counselor is that cool absolutely that's
great
hey I'm not going to come to this event
tomorrow night because it's with me and
my wife go to marriage counseling and
I'm gonna have to miss it great
or hey I've got to move my counseling
appointment because I've got this really
important work thing and I can't miss it
okay or my wife and I took a 70 000
household income pay cut to go from me
running a entire University to me us
moving to another city and me taking a
assignment with a smaller with several
hundred students instead of several
thousand students so that for the next
several years I could get myself well
that was on me not on the not on the
other Institution does that make sense
yeah so it's a context not an excuse if
if the job comes second to the the it
ends up dishonoring the person down that
has hired you guys for help
for your service it's a dishonoring to
them if the job doesn't get done and
someone can say hey I just woke up this
morning with lots of anxiety I'm just
not coming in today
that's not acceptable response
yeah that's what's happened right
historically okay so they can wake up
and have anxiety and if you have a
business that allows them to come in
late great sometimes people are like
Frontline customers sir I need someone
to unlock the door
and you can't call me 15 minutes before
work starts and say I've got anxiety
this morning and so I'm not going to be
there
um that's that's unethical it's it's not
Integris okay it might be that I gotta
get myself to to the office and open the
door and I'm going to call some people
to come in and cover my shift for me
because I can't I gotta go and I've been
there before
I gotta get out of here but I still had
to go open the door and maybe it's
creating a phone tree so that if
somebody wakes up and they are really
struggling and you've met with them and
you've got a note from their therapist
or from the Ada office or whatever
that you've got a phone tree that that
person can reach out and call but it's
going to be their responsibility to make
that call
does that make sense
yeah yeah it does it's it's it's a both
end
um you have to
take care of business you can't just not
show up to work or you can't work here
okay right um here's the third one you
have to model this
you have to model it that means you have
to be open about your what you are
experiencing and your personal
challenges with resp with
um appropriate boundaries
okay meaning that I'm supposed to tell
them uh what's going on with other
people or no no no no never ever do that
myself what I'm saying here if you have
if you are struggling with something if
you get tired if you get exhausted you
get burned out you're going to marriage
counseling that during a staff meeting
you let everybody know hey I'm knocking
off it on Tuesday because I'm gonna go
I'm seeing a professional to work
through some stuff
um you are modeling oh that's okay
Andy you're also modeling
I'm not telling you that I've got
depression I'm not telling you that my
husband cheated on me we're going to
marriage couns am I telling you any of
the glory details I'm just telling you
that I'm going to take care of myself
and then later on you point back to the
way you did it as the model so when
someone says okay I'm struggling to say
stop remember when I did it I'll let you
know I'm going to get help and Care
what's your what Your diagnosis is
between you and your therapist between
you and your doctor
right does that make sense and and you
got to come to work you got to be at
work
so so for people that aren't coming into
work because that's kind of one of the
issues with the around anxiety
um do you do you allow them to work
remotely my fear is that they're not
going to work remotely or do you you
know let them take the time off but then
it impacts other people that have to
take over their workload you know what I
mean at some point it's just not going
to work out but up until then what how
do you how do I handle that sort of a
situation I don't have any problem and
this isn't popular with large
corporations when you when you get super
big it becomes very unwieldy and so
that's where you get these big blanket
policies that we don't do this or we do
this when you have a staff of 10
um I like it how my boss Dave Ramsey did
it once he stood up and said we are
growing company size and there's a
particular leader who's got a particular
situation
and I'm the boss and so here's how I'm
helping him out
here's how I'm helping her out and it
it was a one-off situation and there's
been multiple one-offs here at where I
work at Ramsey Solutions every every
Leader's got the up the ability to do
some one-offs with their people but
here's the catch for a limited time
so it might be someone coming and say I
am doubled over with anxiety I'm really
struggling I just can't breathe I need
some time and you might be able to say I
can do two weeks
for two weeks someone else is going to
pick up your shift you are going to have
to come up in that two weeks with
are you able to work here to get your
job done do you have a workable solution
we are a work in the office company and
so we are not ever going to transition
to fully remote and so or we are slowly
moving towards remote we're going to
practice it and we're going to let you
be the guinea pig right but I don't have
any problem with one-offs what I don't
like about one-offs is when they become
very secret hey don't tell anybody but
I'm gonna let you do I wouldn't do it
like that
because it never stays secret and then
it looks it can be discriminatory you
let that person do it you let it's
better just to open it up to the floor
so and so let said I could share with
y'all that she's really struggling or
he's really struggling and so for the
next two weeks they're not gonna be here
it's gonna mean you're gonna have to
pick up a little extra I mean you have
to pick a little extra and then within
two weeks we're gonna have a resolution
on how this how what happens next
okay but it's got It's Time limited
right and it might be you need to reach
out I wouldn't even get in the business
of calling the therapist I I take that
back but it's time limiting and at some
point you have to sit down and say hey
um you're unable to complete the core
tasks of this job
The Bona Fide occupational requirements
of this position right
and this is a hard hard conversation and
maybe I think the workable I think the
workable solution idea is a good one
um because you know one thought I had
was well you give them a a month to not
do that anymore but then if there's no
solution attached to it it'll just
they'll just Resort back to doing it
when they've returned so right and and I
want people I want people to struggle
with is this anxiety or is this
exhaustion
am I is my body signing the alarms that
I need to go get help or I'm just
annoyed this morning I don't feel like
going in because all of us have those
days all of us do and I remember how
hard it was when I was trying to relearn
what my body was trying to tell me and
my signals were all jumbled up because I
ignored them for so long and I
wallpapered over them with busyness and
work and my crushing a workout plan all
these different addictions I had over it
and ultimately I had to learn okay this
is my body saying things are not as they
should be this is anxiety this is what
this feels like
this is me being really exhausted this
is me having a large pizza in half a two
liter bottle of coke all by myself
this is all right fill in the blank fill
in the blank fill in the blank so I do
get it takes some time to parse that
apart
um and I want people to struggle with
that I think that's the path to healing
for all of us the challenge is as an
employer is you can't do other people's
healing for them they've got to be
invested in it themselves again thank
you for being somebody who cares Susan
um try these out relationships but
appropriate distance context not an
excuse context
um but not an excuse and model it give
those a shot and then to holler back at
me if I can help moving forward